soon I will be consumed by them by the
latter the dark is in every human strong
human 20 mankind are more than pure dark
but two humans have light and dark
within them even in his last moments
Artorius thought sir
my bank of the spread of the abyss II
must be stopped the furtive pygmy was
the first human it claimed the Dark Soul
and waited for the fire to subside for
while the other Souls grew weaker the
Dark Soul grew stronger
the Lord souls of light and dark seemed
to be in counterbalance to one another
while Gwyn fathered the age of fire and
set up his kingdom
the pygmy shattered the Dark Soul and
fathered humanity this mysterious black
sprite was the powerful life force of
humans driving them to love hate create
and destroy the most pure hearted humans
were able to create more humanity within
themselves the Dark Soul is unique in
that it can grow and spread through
humans by the time the furtive pygmy was
killed it was already too late
the Dark Soul had already been split and
it continued to split and grow like a
disease and as the darkness grew the
flames did fade and Gwynn's Kingdom
began to fall with the fading flame came
the rising dark and those who would see
it grow stronger the dragons and the
Giants were not the only things in the
age of ancients from the Stone dragons
came Drake's hydras and primordial
serpents you have to wonder how much
influence the serpents have had because
all throughout the ages the serpents
have always achieved their desires at
the expense of others we know of one
serpent calf who hides in the shadows to
see the shadows grow it was the
manipulations of such a serpent that led
to an upturned grave and the doom of all
the seal believe it or not
ghoulish heel has brought the abyss upon
itself fooled by that toothy serpent
they upturned the grave of primeval man
and incited his ornery wrath what could
they have been thinking
nanus the father of the abyss primeval
human and once the furtive pygmy
unleashed the wrath of the dark upon
oolacile corrupting and transforming its
denizens into monsters knight artorias
came to stop this but such a hero has
marry a murmur of dark without doubt he
will be sworn fabulous overcome by its
utter blackness indeed the abyss may be
stopped
and artorias was slain but a hero from a
time distant yet near killed the
primeval human in his name and ended its
rampage but Qarth simply moved on to his
next target Gwyn split his own soul and
handed it to the four kings who ruled
over New Londo it was a reward for their
foresight but the Kings only wanted more
power long ago the four kings were
powerful men only their hearts
were weak when an evil serpent dangled
the art of lifedrain
before them they were unable to resist
and became pawns of evil Quinn had
already seen what happened in all Aseel
the spread of the abyss had to be
contained wherever it was found he
flooded New Londo in an attempt to seal
the darkness and the Kings it was around
this time that the other gods started to
panic the goddesses fina and Volker had
already been forcibly exiled by safe and
Gwynn's own daughter gwynevere was to
follow she fled with the flame god flan
and abandoned her father meanwhile the
witch of izalith was working on a plan
she was attempting to duplicate the
first flame using her own magic and her
Lord soul perhaps this could fight off
the gathering dark but this plan did not
work in fact it backfired engulfing the
witch her sisters and the city of
izalith her soul of life became twisted
creating malformed demonic chaotic life
and the world saw its first demons the
silver Knights of Gwyn still remained
from the war against the Dragons and
they were ordered to fight against the
chaos demons despite the bravery of the
Knights they were repelled by the bed of
chaos the silver knights retreated to
Guin with armor blackened and charred
from their journey to izalith they had
failed
Gwyn's downfall is absolute he's lost
his kingdom his knights his wife
children and Friends for the stronger
the light the thicker the shadows fall
there are no happy endings in Lordran
even if you do no wrong tragedy finds
you
maybe you're searching for the light in
a dark place maybe you're fighting to
keep your sister alive
whether you're adventuring for the sake
of adventure or risking your life for
your Lord it will do no good
but despite futility we do these things
anyway by fighting against the
inevitable we carve meaning from
meaninglessness Gwyn travels to the kiln
with his remaining Knights and
sacrifices himself as fuel for the first
flame just so it can burn a little
longer for the living the dark will
eventually overcome the fading flame but
not without a fight
you